how many friends do you have most of us
would rush to think of a very high
number to have to admit to having very
few is in our societies a marker of
great shame and failure but what if
being lonely were actually a sign of
being something else an interesting
emotionally sincere and thoughtful
person what if in a world of superficial
friendships lonely was just what a more
serious person tended naturally to be
with this in mind we might take an
unusual test that seeks to explore how
few friends we might actually have one
what do most of your so-called friends
not understand about you you might have
many friends but how well aligned are
they really once you take off a
Sentimental lens how many things are
there that you wouldn't dream of
mentioning how much of your life has to
go on in secret because no one
understands two who might you turn to if
you were disgraced as a result of some
error on your part if a large slice of
the world were to turn against you would
there be anyone who would continue to
see you as you and not just as the
weirder or loser that Society made you
out to be who could see you as both
guilty maybe and still worthy of
kindness three who would you be able to
tell if there was a big problem in your
relationship what if for example you'd
had an affair or were drawn to theide
idea of having one what if your lovered
cooled despite there being three small
children in your household who could
tolerate your destruction of society's
cherished ideals of love four with whom
if anyone could you discuss your true
insecurities or complexities around sex
although Society at least in many parts
of the world likes to pretend it's
immensely open it's a radically
different matter when it comes to our
erotic lives It's tricky to be an
elegantly dressed Dean of the business
faculty who wants to or a tank commander
who or a mother of two Delightful
Children with a longing
to five who likes the idiot in you
anyone can like the sensible version of
us but who can tolerate the idiot who
lurks inside all of us the one who's up
late at night doing silly things who
spills things down their front who
messes up at work and says strange
things to themselves in a bit to stay
calm such questions deliberately set the
bar for friendship far higher than you
usual we might having taken this test
realize that we have very few friends
indeed perhaps even none at all this is
no matter for panic or shame many of us
are in fact in the very same position
and the more of us can realize this the
more we can stop pretending that
friendship is as common as we say it is
the less isolated we can feel for not
believing in the sentimental picture we
presently have a friendship the reier we
can be to one day build a friendship
truly worthy of the name